OK, I want to deal now with something that
many of you and I have been noticing about
coronavirus lately.
Cases have exploded.
I mean, just insane numbers of cases and it's
specifically in some states and not in others.
But the death numbers have not been high for
now.
That's a good thing.
I don't want anybody catching coronavirus.
I don't want anybody dying from Corona virus.
But the question is, based on the case numbers,
we would expect deaths to be higher in some
of these states, especially ones where we're
learning that the I.C.E. user maxed out.
So what's going on there now is a reminder.
I have no political perspective here.
My my ideology on the virus is health.
It just so happens the president we have has
failed miserably on corona virus.
But I want to find the real explanation and
I want to find the truth.
So here's a few ideas that have been proposed
about why there have been so many cases, but
relatively fewer deaths than we were seeing
a few months ago.
OK.
One possibility that's been proposed is that
we are getting better at treating Corona virus.
In other words, if you get sick enough to
go into the hospital, doctors are now better
at treating because we have three months of
experience and thus you would expect the death
rate to be lower.
In fact, there is a study called Decreased
in Hospital Mortality in patients with Koven
19 pneumonia.
And it says that in a lot of countries, fewer
people are going to the hospital and dying.
And it's a combination of some hospitals being
less overrun with a better understanding of
how patients should be treated.
Reminder.
That's why we locked down.
When you locked down, you keep the hospitals
less full.
So the sick people get better care and you
allow time for doctors to learn to properly
treat the disease.
So hopefully, by the time you get it or your
loved one gets it, the medical system is better
equipped to treat.
Very good.
That's one possibility.
Second possibility for why there are a ton
of cases and not as many deaths is that we
just haven't seen the deaths yet.
OK, the idea in general is it's like twenty
two days from test to death.
You get a positive test.
It's often five days before you end up in
the hospital.
It's often 17 days from hospitalization to
death.
So it's like a 22 day delay between cases
and deaths.
The current spike started, I call it June
16th.
If this is the explanation that we've just
haven't seen the deaths yet, we would expect
deaths to spike around June 7th or 8th.
I hope it doesn't happen if it is that that's
what's going on.
The death numbers are going to get very, very
ugly very, very soon.
Third possibility for why we have so many
cases and relatively few deaths is that older
folks are better protecting themselves and
staying home.
And it's the younger people that are testing
positive younger people, much more likely
not to need hospitalization, much less likely
to die.
That would be a possibility.
We don't have the full data on that.
That's really an empirical question.
We just don't have the full data on that.
So we would have to see.
I know that there are some cities that are
saying we are seeing more young people get
it, fewer older folks get it.
We need to see that at the state level, at
the federal level.
Lastly, there are some doctors arguing that
the virus is mutating to be less serious,
that at this point the virus has weakened
and thus those who are infected.
Are getting a less serious version of it than
what was going around in March, April and
early May.
I don't want to say too much about that because
we don't know that to be the case.
It's a hypothesis.
It presumably could be tested empirically.
That's not been done.
Most doctors are saying there is not actually
evidence of that right now.
And so I don't want to risk giving people
the wrong idea with something that has not
been demonstrated to be true.
Still a lot to learn, but those are four of
the possibilities for why so far we are seeing
unconscionable spikes in the number of cases,
but not yet, not yet seen.
And hopefully we won't see corresponding numbers
of deaths.
Let me know what you think about this.